SMIL r-rahman r-rahim al-hamdu lillahi
rabbil alameen was salat wa salam ala
rasulina Kareem Ali early he was happy
[Arabic recitation]
Australian which had won a muhammadan
salam aliekum wa rahamtullah thank you
all for joining us this evening and our
third installation of saddle my dad he
had a higher lay bed authored by the
late and profound highly esteemed
scholar and share of Islam shamsid-deen
[Arabic recitation]
discussed in our previous lecture or in
our previous sitting we discussed the
choices that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
makes for his creation and the bulk of
what we discussed in our last discussion
revolved around a statement of allah in
surat al tussles in which Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala says war a bouquet
of local nyesha way a star machan
[Arabic recitation]
what He wills and chooses from amongst
that creation what he chooses what he
decides the choice of elevating some
above others and giving positions to
some over others this is part of the
choice of Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala it
is it is to his discretion if we truly
understand this then we will be able to
rid our hearts of jealousy and envy and
hasit the root of an acid the root of
jealousy
of envy unhealthy envy and jealousy is
that an individual is not pleased is not
satisfied is not contented by that which
Allah has chosen for him and that which
Allah has chosen for others this is the
source of jealousy I've no claim on him
Allah in one of his books a book which
is a collection of reflections of his
that he has named as Follette in this
book he mentions the pillars of Khufu
the pillars of disbelief just as Islam
has pillars disbelief its opposite also
has pillars and he mentions that the
pillars of disbelief are for he mentions
arrogance anger jealousy and desire he
mentions that these four are the pillars
of disbelief he mentions that any people
or person that has been destroyed by a
law that I have been mentioned in the
Quran if you look close enough you will
find all of these four traits in them in
one way or another and he mentions that
jealousy prevents a person from desiring
good for others and wishing others will
jealousy and envy is one of the pillars
of ko4 because it breaks down the social
structure of the Muslim community and
jealousy he mentions the only way to
remove jealousy from a person's heart is
to find tranquility and learn to become
contented with what a loss of Hanna what
Allah has decreed and chosen this is the
only way
and so once we understand that and we
understand that it is a law who is
making the choices and when a person
exhibits jealousy of another he is
essentially disagreeing with a loss of
had no - eyelids choices he is
essentially saying Allah has chosen this
and I beg to differ I disagree and that
that is a mouthful when you think of it
in that sense now we move on to the way
that the prophets all alone you
acetamide wobble and the reason that we
begin with this is most of the books of
filk begin with the Book of Allah meeya
and mu and of Pajaro most books of filk
they follow the structure that the
prophet sallallaahu seldom has laid out
all the way back to the book of allah
Mamelodi rahim allah the book of allah
man Malik right they they structured the
their books respectively according to
the structure of the narration of the
prophets all alone you asylum which most
of us are familiar with in which he was
asked by gibreel what is Islam he said
Islam and then he states the five
pillars of Islam he begins with prayer
and then zakat and then hedge and then
so yeah in the narration of Almaty and
the narration of Imam Muslim it is
slowly zakah cm fasting and then Hajj
and most of the scholars will structure
their books in this way Abdul kayum
rahim allah begins here with describing
to us the way that the prophets all
alone rusle made will do he says that
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
usually would make will do for every
single prayer even if he already had
will do even if he didn't break his will
and sometimes he would make one will go
and pray more than
one prayer off of that one will do now
this goes back to the generality of the
statement of allah subhanahu wata'ala
which is the sixth verse of the fifth
chapter Surat al-ma'idah on which Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala says yeah yo holla
Dena Amman in a quantum allah salla fell
Saluja come my idea Camille Muffat
hwang-sabu
be Russia come well Julie come ll kabane
los subhana WA Ta'ala says o you who
have believed if you wish to make
swallow if you wish to pray then begin
with washing your faces your arms to
including the elbows wipe over your
heads and ears it mentions just wipe
over your heads
ears are part of the head and wash your
feet to include the ankles now we
understand from the generality of this
verse that Allah says if you wish to
pray then maple do so based on this
understanding the prophets all alone I
do salem every time he would stand to
pray would make will do but that's not
what is necessary that is not what is
wedge it or obligated that is not
binding it is binding upon a person to
make will do when they have done
something that nullifies their their
will do however the better thing to do
and what is encouraged is to make will
do for each and every slow so we have
most of the prophets all along I loose
items life he would make will do for
every salah and sometimes he would make
more than once Allah with the same
laboum this is understood from many
different texts how
ever one comes to mind of the statement
of oma
even though but all do you love one I
know in which in the conquest of Mecca
the prophet sallallaahu said Allah made
all five prayers that day and night with
one mobile and armor of yellow on who
said to him o Messenger of Allah I
observed you doing today something that
I have never seen you do before and the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam said
to him that which means file to who
uncus then I did that on purpose and
that is that he made will do one time
and prayed all of the prayers so from
this narration we understand that the
most and the majority of his actions
would be to make will do for every
prayer and the exception was to make
more than one pray or on the same will
do if nakiya mentions that the Prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would often
make will do with one would aim would is
equivalent roughly to about 650
milliliters that is about roughly how
much a wood is so for example a bottle
of water this bottle of water is about
500 milliliters a little bit more than
this bottle of water would be how much
the prophet sallal omar the asylum would
use to make will do that's extremely
conservative when you think about the
size of the prophets a little know mile
you send him he was a pretty big man and
so we understand from this that the
usually he would make will do with about
a month sometimes two thirds of them
would which would be roughly about the
size of a of an average
bottle of water and sometimes a little
more right but that was about roughly
how much he would use to make water to
make will move and he sallallahu aleyhi
wa salem would be extremely conservative
in the way that he used the water for
will boom and he's all alone i knew a
salem on numerous occasions warned his
followers and his disciples he warned
his companions from using too much water
to make wool and in one narration which
is has an acceptable chain of narration
when we gather all of the chains of
narration that he said do not waste
water do not be wasteful in making your
will do even if you are making your will
bull from a flowing river and the
prophet sallallaahu alayhi wa salem as
if Nilayam here says would and has made
will do by washing each of his limbs and
and parts of his body once each twice
each and three times each there is a
fourth and that is that he would wash
some of his limbs twice and others three
times so now we have for all three of
the first are mentioned in sahih
al-bukhari in succession in the book of
a little this is how he would make will
do he would make will do most often by
washing each limb three times so he
would wash his face three times he would
you know the mouth and nose are part of
the face he would wash each arm
including the elbow three times each
right and he was also narrated to have
washed each of these parts of his body
two times each he was also narrated to
have washed each of
these parts of his body one time each
and that is the minimum so if you were
to ask what is obligatory we would say
one time and if you were to say what is
good we would say two times if you were
to say what is best we would say three
times each and that is what most Muslims
know also in a narration collected by
Lim emili´s Lim he was narrated to have
washed some of his limbs twice and
others three times and this is something
that he would do occasionally as if
[Arabic recitation]
mentions that the prophet sallallaahu
alayhi wa salem would also rinse his
mouth and his nose sometimes once with
every hand full of water sometimes with
once in every two handfuls of water and
sometimes once with every handful three
for each one now he mentions this in a
very specific way and I will break that
down insha Allah the way that the
Prophet Salla low annua seldom was
narrated to have made will do and rinsed
his mouth and nose someone may say well
the mouth and nose aren't mentioned in
the Quran and we would say yes the mouth
and nose are mentioned in the Quran in
the generality of the command of Allah
in the preceding verse that we had
mentioned in the generality of his
statement o you who have believed if you
wish to pray then wash your faces the
mouth and nose are part of the face we
know this because the prophet salaallah
alayhi wa salem never was narrated to
have made will blue and not washed
rinsed his mouth and nose this has never
been authenticated and so we know that
because he did it every single time we
know that he understood that the mouth
and nose are
part of the face that Allah commanded
that we wash each time we make will rule
now he would rinse his mouth and nose
together all of the Sunnah has mentioned
that he he would always do them together
put water in his hand some in his mouth
some in his nose he would spit out and
then with his left hand
excuse me with his left hand he would
blow his nose so he would fill his hand
up one that and then the second
time then the third time right together
the other the second way that if Nokia
mentions is two times right so one and
two and a third way which is a little
bit more difficult is that he would do
all three with the same hand full of
water so he would fill his hand up with
water one two three okay he says and the
prophet sallallaahu alayhi wa salem
would always do his mouth and nose
together when he would rinse his mouth
and nose well someone may ask well what
about when a person does his mouth three
times and then does his nose three times
we would say that is acceptable the
scholars of fil Rahim 'him Allah have
mentioned that that is valid and there
is a difference between valid and the
Sunnah that's that's kind of an
interesting concept if you think about
it how can there be a difference between
that which is valid and that which is
the Sunnah and we will say something
being valid means that it meets the bare
minimum of criteria to be acceptable but
not everything that is valid is the
sunnah of the prophet salallahu alayhi
wa salem so we could say it in another
way everything that is
the Sunnah is valid but not everything
that is valid is the Sun now well let's
take an example to try to make that a
little easier there's a narration in
which the prophet salaallah alayhi wa
salem had dispatched a battalion or
troops and he had placed someone in
charge of this this small army and the
way that it would be is that the person
the prophet sallallaahu asylum when he
would choose who to make the the general
over this particular army or Calvary he
would choose the one who was most
knowledgeable amongst them doesn't mean
that he would send the most
knowledgeable of his companions no
amongst those who are going he would
send the most knowledgeable and that
person would also be the one that would
lead prayer he is the immediate right
and in sahih al-bukhari it's narrated
that one of these generals of his every
time he would lead Salah he would end
his recitation with reciting surat
al-ikhlas
who Allah I had a low summit let me lead
will emulate dwell America level Khufu
and act and every single Salah either
each Erica or at the end of the the
recitation entirely in the second Mecca
he would recite this his companion said
why are you doing this I would the
Prophet SAW Allah while he was seldom
doesn't do this he said this is a
chapter of the Quran that I love and I
will continue to do it and they asked
the Prophet SAW alone while you assail
him about this and he said to them ask
him why he does this so they asked him
and he said because it is the
description of a law and I love this
surah and so the prophets Allah loan you
asylum when informed of this reason he
said
inform him that just as he has loved
this chapter Allah has loved him now
this is what is called a lil crop in the
science of hadith this is considered
something that the prophet sallallaahu a
salem acknowledged he acknowledged now
this is valid however is this the Sunna
meaning is this something that the
prophets all along I knew asylum would
do no because we have no narration that
he would end each prayer or each raka of
each prayer in recitation with surat
al-ikhlas and no doubt he loved this
chapter more than this companion and so
he acknowledges that what the companion
is doing is falls into the generality of
permissible but he does not do it
himself in a consistent basis which
articulates to us that it is valid but
is not necessarily the Sunnah it's
important for us to understand the
distinction and so if a person were to
rinse his mouth alone and then take
another handful of water to rinse his
nose we would say this is valid but this
is not necessarily the Sunnah the sunnah
of the prophet salallahu alayhi wasalam
is to use one of Elfa one handful for
both his mouth and his nose together
every no ka Meraki Mahalo to Ilyich
continues on to say and the Prophet
sallallahu aleyhi wa salem would take
the water into his nose from his right
hand okay and he would Yin thethethe
which means he would blow his nose and
he would use his left hand to pinch as
he blew his nose okay so he is using the
right hand to take the water into his
nose the left hand to blow out of his
nose so low low on your Salem when
making booboo
he says little deal Rehema hello' to
isla and on occasions he would wipe over
the entirety of his head in making Lulu
and sometimes he would go forward and
then backward okay so what is meant here
is that the profits all alone Lu asylum
would wipe over his head just that
so sometimes he would wet his hands and
go over his head just this one time
the entirety of his head and sometimes
you could be a no beat him Anna well you
would two-bit meaning he would wipe this
way and then back over towards the front
now it's a strange wording in the
narration because this is described to
us in soon and every day would the
companion says the prophets all alone
Uwe Salem he would wipe his hands
forward and then backward and so a
person may understand this to be
starting here and then going back but
that's not what is meant the scholars
have told us that what is meant by this
is that the companion would be standing
behind the prophet sallallaahu a send
him so his perspective is when the
prophets all alone while you asylum
would wipe backwards he would start at
his own face and go backwards according
to the perspective of the narrator he
would be coming back towards the
narrator so he would be bringing his
hands towards the narrator and then back
to where they came from so it's an issue
of perspective so he was either narrated
to have wiped his head once or wipe to
the back and then come back over towards
the face and end there and it he
mentions there that it has never been
authenticated that the prophets all
alone on you asylum would only wipe over
a portion of his head rather what has
been Nair
created is that he would wipe a portion
of his forehead and then he would
conclude and complete wiping over the
rest of his Amma which is a turban right
so what does this mean well in some of
the medev even the Med hub of Amash
every about him Allah and understanding
this verse the verse of Allu in Surat
al-ma'idah they understand that even if
you wipe over a small portion of your
head honey in some of that hit is
one-third two-thirds some mentioned even
just a little bit over the temple that
you have done what Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala has commanded yet if no Khayyam
mentions here to us that it has never
been narrated that the prophet soul
alone you a salem when wiping over his
bare head would wipe only over a portion
of his head it has always been narrated
that he would wipe over the entirety of
his head with both of his hands dampened
likewise he mentions that what has been
narrated as well is that when the
prophet sallallaahu a seldom would be
wearing some kind of headdress or head
wear that would be something of an
annoyance to remove he would just wipe
over that head wear right and he
mentions here the amana the way that the
the way that the arabs in the time of
the prophet saw alone i li wa salem
would wear there on that and they would
wear their turbans as they would wrap
the turban in a way and then it would go
underneath their chin and sometimes it
would go towards the back the Prophet
SAW alone I Lee was seldom in the later
parts of his life would just have the
ends of the turban going back between
his shoulder blades
and so this turban if you take it off
and wipe over your head and then put it
back on it's not going
to be the way it was when you first put
it on and so you're now I'm going to be
forced to unravel it and rewrap it which
can be something of an annoyance if
you're going to do this five times in a
day and so out of well Magi alaykum
Feeny Maharaj Allah has not placed any
burden upon you all in your religion it
is permissible that if a person is
wearing something that is similar as
head wear that a person may wipe over
their forehead and then finish up over
the Annamma a hat does not fall into
that because there is no annoyance and
taking the hat off and putting it back
on rather this is only for a turban
something that is elaborate something
that takes some additional effort to put
on as well the theme of a woman by
FEMA I mean the what we call in
philosophy in the men deed I for some
reason in our dialect in felis leo
anyways when we say tomorrow we mean the
cup so when they say she wears a Hammad
that means she wears a new club and
that's not what is meant by FEMA in the
classical Arabic and in the words of the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam el tema in
the Sunnah is that which covers the head
and so if a woman is wearing her hey jab
right she can she does not have to take
her hijab off to make woo
rather she would just wipe over a
portion of her forehead and then finish
that will do over her hijab
sedima the wife of the Prophet SAW
alone he wa salem was narrated to have
done and as the Prophet SAW alone I
Lewis Elam did with regards to his
terminal ileum then mentions that it has
never been narrated that the prophet
salaallah alayhi wa salem made will do
without rinsing his mouth and nose
and so rinsing the mouth and nose we
understand our part of the completion of
washing one's face if a person does not
rinse his mouth and nose he has not
washed his face and that would not be
valid and he says and it has never been
narrated that he left out his mouth and
nose ever likewise it has never been the
will rule the ablution of the Prophet
sallallahu wasallam was always narrated
to be in order and in quick succession
it has never been authentically reported
that the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
seldom ever made will do in any other
order than the order mentioned in the
whole on so what does this mean there
are two things here and that is order
and succession what is order in
succession order meaning the order of
the pull on and that is wash your faces
wash your hands including the elbows
wipe over your heads and wash your feet
including the ankles this is the order
and so it has always been narrated that
the prophet sallallaahu a salem would
make will do in this order yes there is
there are narrations such as the
narration of earth man in Asahi ahead
I'll be alone who where he would wash
his hands to the wrist first and then he
would begin with washing his face but
this is not as a matter of obligation
this is a matter of Sunnah if a person
were to skip washing his hands at the
very beginning and only go to washing
his face directly this would be
permissible and this would be correct
and it has been narrated that the
prophet saw alone i leo said Allah made
will blue in that way and that his
companions described his will do in that
way now it's never been narrated that he
made will do and
and switched up the order of that will
do so he begins with wiping his head and
then goes to the arms and then goes to
the face and then goes to the feet or
begins with the feet and works backwards
or something that this has never
been authentically narrated now there is
a narration in one of the Nusa one of
the copies of soon and Abu Dawood and
the book of will do I believe on the
authority of idea bin Ahmadi ketab and
this narration is questionable and the
narration basically states that the
prophet sallallaahu asylum washed his
face and then he washed his arms and
then he did his mouth and nose and then
he wiped over his head yet this
narration when we really investigated we
find that this narration is what the
scholars of hadith refer to as shed this
narration is consider to be and kind of
a one-off or a fluke if you will because
of an issue in the science of hadith
that we will not get into this is the
only evidence to my knowledge that the
Prophet SAW Allah Allah seldom ever made
will do out of order and this narration
is not authentic it is highly
questionable the majority of scholars of
hadith view this narration to be
inauthentic it is not found in all of
the copies of be there with all of the
versions it's only found in some of the
narrations of son and everyday wood and
likewise the majority of the scholarship
of Islam agree that a person must make
will do in order now that's interesting
because when we see in the Quran the way
that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
placed they will do in order we see that
allah intended by the way he structured
the verse of the rule and that sixth
verse of the fifth chapter
so total merida he structured it in a
way that articulates that the order of
that of those things too
that is intended in itself so for
example there are things that you wash
and there are things that you wipe right
so you wash your face you wash your arms
including the elbows you wash your feet
but you wipe over your head now what we
would a way to put this in order would
be to put the things that you wash right
on together and then the things that you
wipe together that would be a more that
would be a more intelligible way of
articulating things by categorizing them
those things that you wash those things
that you wipe but when we see that Allah
mentions wash wash wipe wash we see that
the order that that one that is wipe
over your heads is stuck in the middle
the only reason that we can find for
that is that the order a total tube is
actually intended in itself this is what
the scholars of teff seeit have told us
likewise the ears are part of the head
there's a narration in Assen answer
turneth Timothy on the authority of I
behold Iowa with a authentic chain of
narration that the Prophet sallallahu
wasallam sallallahu alayhi wasallam I
said you do nanny Miniver us he said the
two ears are part of the head the two
ears are part of the head so when Allah
says and wipe over your head
the ears are part of the head so we wipe
over them as the Prophet SAW alone while
you asylum was narrated to and that is
he would take his index fingers and
place them inside he would wipe the
front of his ears with his index fingers
and the backs of his ears with his
thumbs this is how he would make all do
sol Aloha
you will send them and wipe over his
ears he would also not take fresh water
for his ears so he would not wet his
hands wipe over his head and then wet
his hands and do his ears no it would be
wipe his hands
what wet his hands wipe over his head
wipe over his ears with the same water
right this is these are what the
narrations tell us about the prophets
Allah lo my newest items will boom the
second thing is succession so if no
clarium tells us here that the prophet
sallallaahu alayhi wa salem would always
make wobble in order in succession
what is succession we discussed what in
order means now we want to discuss in
succession
well succession is that they he would
follow in quick succession each of the
rest of will do so if a person for
example said okay well you know what I
don't putting my feet up in my sink
in my bathroom at home so I'm gonna make
a rule I'm gonna wash everything but
then when I get to the Masjid I'm gonna
do my feet so they do everything at home
they jump in the car half hour later
they arrive at the Masjid and they only
wash their feet at the message this will
do is not valid this rule cannot be
valid because a Tele
is part of the pillars or wedgie bet
based on the different classifications
of the scholars is a part of the pillars
or obligations of abou an order for a
will do to be valid that will must be
performed in succession some of the
scholars have mentioned the yardstick of
succession is that by the time you wash
your final limb the first one has not
dried yet we're talking about air drying
right so if I begin with washing my face
by the time I get to washing my feet my
face should still be wet if my face has
had enough time to air dry
and before I get to my feet you know I
make will do I reach our wipe over my
head then I get a phone call I stop and
I talk on the phone for 15 minutes my
face is dry I cannot now just make just
wash my feet now I have to start over
because the pillar of a Tele succession
has been interrupted brief interruption
is not a problem you know you're making
with all your buddy walks in so I want a
comb hey how you doing what's going on
you say something to someone someone
that asks you a question something that
takes a minute or less this will this is
no problem this will not affect your
will however what will affect your will
blue is long intermissions long
interruptions this will affect the
validity of your will do finally for
tonight we would to discuss how the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam would wipe
over his Footwear he mentions here
volcanium salud lady Bellamy Hakuna
[Arabic recitation]
I am Sehun a him out see he hid the vol
hero Huma what about Lena Huma he says
that the prophets all alone on us Elam
would wash his feet if he didn't have
anything on his feet if he didn't have
any leather socks if he didn't have any
cotton socks or something
l.joe rub is something that is made out
of usually cotton but anything that is
not leather and a hoof is a type of
shoe but it's a very hard leather which
we will discuss in our next lecture
insha'Allah we will go into much detail
there if his feet were bare he would
wash them so alone he was settling so he
would not put on anything to wipe over
and he would not take anything off to
wash rather as his feet was when he made
will do that is how he would treat them
likewise he would wipe over both of his
ears the front and the backs of their
ears of his ears just
as we had described before inshallah our
next lecture we will discuss next week
the way in which the Prophet SAW alone
our newest Adam would complete his will
do we will discuss as well issues of
saying bismillah at s mia we will also
discuss some of the things that the
prophet saw Aloha new asylum would and
would not do and will blue that people
do and that is enough for us today
inshallah we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
to teach us of his prophets Sunnah that
which we are ignorant of to remind us of
his Sunnah that which we have made made
to forget and to benefit us from that
which he teaches us and reminds us well
of alum Wasel allah wa sallim ala nabina
muhammad while early he was high Vth
made